c'est qu'à cause de toi pas grâce à toi
cause de toi tout le week-end on ne va
parler que de toi un mince alors mes
frères ont salué tout le week-end une
déflagration mais la mesure zéro
j'avais j'ai découvert des chaînes qui
n'existaient même pas un moment williams
a sorti des chaînes alors c'est là bas
je connais pas la cas moi est ce que tu
veux qu'on revienne là-dessus tout de
suite à vendre et de surba après on
verra si l'ouest
tu as demain soir à ce qu'on a un truc à
vous annoncer aussi camier moi mais
c'est vrai que mon cas ça a été un truc
de ouf ça veut dire tout le week-end
c'est c'est comme s'ils s'étaient plus
avec ta meuf lui il ya des mecs qui
t'appelle tu dit ouais ta meuf en fait
elle va sur tf1 j'ai vu ta meuf sur
equidia avec un poney rigoler non mais
c'était un enfer alors qu'amy juste on
va on va devoir reprendre ce qui s'est
passé vendredi dernier et a accordé une
interview à pure médias relaient pour
les chiffres juive radio kick and rush
bien ça marche sur virgin radio tu
arrêtes ou pas la radio n'arrête on est
sur un arrêt la section au cm2 soit
commettre la radio c'est sûr non
j'arrête là matinales radio
tout en surveillant ya des ja je tombe
après que ça pas de normes us en foot
les gens aient enfin des choses on a vu
que c'était le soir au quai ce soir sur
nrj
mais pas alors j'enchaîne les gens qui
sont des mecs annonce toutes les radios
wasquehal géré l'annoncé même sur radio
cocktail mais jamais on dit à quelqu'un
couvre mon courrier avant que moi même
je l'ouvrais je suis pas au courant de
trucs
alors non alors donc ta ta ta tonini
interview pour pure médias et adil
aventure tpm paix va prendre fin pour
moi en juin j'en ai parlé longuement
avec cyril c'est vous donc c'est un jeu
cyril féraud je n'ai pas les activer le
front de flammes et je pars avec des
souvenirs incroyables
j'aime profondément cyril merci et toute
l'équipe il à dire il a déchiré mais
c'est la fin d'un cycle
camille combal ozap.com 20 avril du
mieux disant qu'elle a je sais pas
c'était le matin c'est le matin très tôt
je me lève à l'aube alors alors oui
veilleux pourquoi l'avoir annoncée dans
ozap bon parce que c'est le seul qui
lyon paris l'aer est je mets mon demandé
une interview pour la radio pourquoi
ouais bouge pas nous sommes en mai parce
qu'en fait c'était pas là et parce qu'en
fait c'est à dire un truc je n'aurais
pas ce qu'on dirait que je la danse mais
pas cyril ça fait depuis le mois de juin
qui c'est con c'est ma dernière année il
a vraiment pas là où je n'a pas appris
vendredi
non non ça être toi à marc cherry moi
non mais c'est vrai que non mais il y
avait il y avait je regrette puis comme
ozap tu faisais une interview pour la
radio tu t'es dit en même temps ils ont
posé la question nous taper exactement
mon bac et 6 passes ah oui c'est le
principe merci
pour la se passe bien alors c'est ça les
débats alors donc camille va ça sera sa
dernière saison dans tpm p voilà je te
le dis moi mon chéri franchement on en a
parlé ensemble pendant des semaines et
des semaines
c'est vrai que je pense que tu as fait
et moi tu nous apporter énormément dans
touche pas à mon poste pendant six ont
été formidables comme menora voilà l'a
été et c'est vrai qu'à un moment je
comprends qu'ils aient envie de voler de
ses propres ailes et d'être voilà de
faire tes trucs tout ça moi tu sais que
je t'aime mais non mais c'est vrai après
voilà après peut-être que vous avez des
questions voilà premier mais aussi
j'habite c'était vrai qu'on n'a pas
compris le début que tu as été démarché
par d'autres chaînes que c'est alors
sincèrement j'ai on le dit une fois
parce que j'ai pas envie qu'on en parle
tous les soirs parce que moi je viens le
soir c'est pour amuser les gens
s'intéressent pas les jantes à voir où
je vais ce que je gagne on s'en fout
sincèrement ce que tu gagnes une seule
soit nommée une seule fois pour en
parler au moins comme ça ce sera fait je
ne sais pas du tout ce que je fais à la
rentrée sincèrement vraiment j'ai j'ai
aucune idée de ce que je vais faire la
rentrée et je vais pas vous dire ce que
je vais faire pas faire ou quoi pour que
dans six mois sur le plateau vous disiez
maqam il est parti c'est un monteur
finalement il fait ce qui m'a choisi
j'en sais rien maintenant dit rien on
prévoit là aussi je twitte oui oui comme
les sections que ça peut être ici aussi
c'est me faisait pas tout à fait aussi
produit par cyril par exemple ça peut
être aussi produit par thierry oui je
vous dis non c'est sûrement dit tout est
possible sur fabrice est ce que c'est
vrai que tu as été démarché par d'autres
chaînes
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai beaucoup moins d'appels que
ce que les gens semblent la messe
annuelle c'est vrai alors c'est pas le
bon portable mais à venir ce qui s'est
passé ce week-end au stade rigaud alors
très peu de temps après l annonce du
départ de camille et un journaliste qui
a donc it annonce avoir été approché par
quotidien donc j'adorerais qu'il a été
approché donc là il ya des gars qui
arrive alors salut s'écoute la france de
carissa lune c'est francis on va ou non
mais alors donc donc et a démenti tout
de suite tu as dit ah non pas du tout
croix de bois croix de fer une
expression d abel morini bosc
non je ne reprends pas l'équipe
d'arsenal non plus je sais juste qu'on
se retrouve elle s'est fait à ça voilà
donc après on t'a annoncés sont annoncés
partout sont annoncés sur nrj et tmc ont
annoncé aussi maintenant dans le groupe
canal plus et finalement on t'annonce
aussi pour présenter d'als donc dans
cette crise tard pour remplacer
s'impliquer non danse avec les stars
c'est pour remplacer christophe licata
en tardant à prendre ça moi parce que
sauf que j'ai mais sur une beauté danse
avec les stars t'approcher sincèrement
je vous dis franchement je sais pas du
tout ce que je ferai à la rentrée mais
ce que tapie je dirais pas franchement
moi je viens là le soir pour m'amuser
pour 6 pour ça et franchement oui je
vous jure je vais vous dire je vais même
pas vous dire ce qu'on m'a approché ou
pas plus apparemment les gens ils ont
mes propositions avant même que moi je
les ai donc je sais pas comment c'est
possible
et sincèrement j'ai des contacts avec
tant de gens je n'ai rien décidé et je
n'ai pas du tout je suis là si tu sais
pas où aller et battait bien chez nous
avoue même très faible voilà gilles amis
vous fait une grave erreur
[Rires]
non mais là mais on n'est pas là pour
faire le débat j'ai l'impression que
quoi que je fasse
est-ce que j'entendrais l'an prochain
justement la question sera bref ça sera
toujours mon amie camille paix sur a
toujours la famille bon voilà non mais
c'est vrai toujours voilà oui donc
arrêté de même gérer sais pas ce que je
fais je fais une erreur du genre de
questions le groupe tf1 étant quand même
en voie de putréfaction gilson sérieuse
dans les sous sols un bon alex ans et
pas bombarder bagages à main vous dites
que tout ira bien même s'il va sur tf1
voir pire sur tmc à c'est autre chose ça
[Rires]
la question compte qu'on a cru
comprendre dans l'interview c'est est-ce
que tu pars parce que tu es déçu qu'on
ne propose pas plus de choses sur le
groupe canal+ et du coup tu as envie
d'aller à voir ailleurs ce qui se passe
pas du tout sincèrement ça revienne
annonce à 100 je sais pas du tout en
vrai on me dit on me sort des trucs je
sais pas du tout ce que propose pas
d'assèchement je peux rien dire je vais
vous dire après vous allez dire ah ils
disent pas la vérité quand il était là
sincèrement je finis avec le vieux juste
mais je sais pas non non on va lâcher sa
qualité de la question de sur le truc
conseil je peux défendre mais c'est que
pour l'instant ils arrêtent des
baignoires il n'est pas impossible pour
travailler ensemble à camille que kémi
travail avec camille que groupe canal+
travail camille on fasse une compil avec
kelly non mais regardez ses avocats
n'ont pas pour l'instant le seul bruit
mais que etc et les blocs a pour
l'instant t c'est pas et ils n'arrivent
pas campagne mais parce qu'on s'entend
mal ou adrien c'est que on se l'était
dit je jure que c'est vrai en juin
dernier on s'était dit ensemble avec
camille et il m'avait dit lui-même voilà
ma dernière saison et je comprends pour
laquelle mais ça fait six ans et non
mais je vais achever de 2 ma campagne
moi je rêvais de faire de la télé j'ai
envie de faire plein d'autres choses
fabrice est le cas dans le monde du
sprint fait plein de choses dites est un
truc j'ai envie de temps que tu étais
c'était plein de trucs j'ai envie de me
surprendre jean nature panjabi de tester
des choses m'amuser ça fait six ans j'ai
des payeurs souvenirs je n'aurai pas de
meilleur souvenir qu'ici dans toute ma
carrière je garderai toute ma vie je
voudrais tous même la mauvaise foi dans
mon coeur et dans mon coeur sincèrement
mais il faut aussi savoir essayer des
nouveaux trucs et peut-être se plante
était de s'amuser mais j'en meurs
d'envié
franchement jean blanc qu'est ce t'en
penses quoi mais moi je pense que c'est
la fin d'un cycle pour camille c'est
tout il a donné si merveilleuse année
c'était mission a régalé tout le monde
je comprends qu'une envie de faire autre
chose il me reste d'allant et voilà la
ville attend quoi
ce qu'est ce qu'il vient de dire est
très beau quintilla dit que ce sera son
meilleur souvenir et vaut mieux qu'ils
partent avant qui commençait à s'ennuyer
peut-être aussi qu'il ait l'impression
de tourner en rond
oui en justice et avait pour idée de
partir pour l'année prochaine faire
l'émission prenant l'accent est
asiatique change de voie si on a une
dernière question intéressante pour
gamines juste moi la question que je me
posais et qu'ils s'opposent tous les
téléspectateurs
c'est juste franchement pourquoi tu
arrêtes tes pmt voilà c'est la vraie la
voilà c'est tout c'est la seule vraie
question
donc on l'a dit un petit peu tout et tu
peux le dire quand même un don des
mauves asie moi j'aimerais te voilà
c'est la fin si on a kiffé six ans c'est
énorme dans une vie j'aurais même pas
cru resté un jour six ans dans une
émission
j'aime cyril j'aime les copains revanche
très heureux voilà j'ai envie de faire
d'autres trucs et de me planter avec
ckoi avec panache ou verra mais j'ai
envie de faire des trucs j'ai envie de
aujourd'hui je alors sincèrement je ne
sais pas où je vais pas du tout est
vraiment je vous encore une fois c'est
pas pour botter en touche de la langue
de bois c'est juste que j'ai pas envie
qu après on est quand même je pense
plutôt très amis en six ans et que vous
disiez bayan n'est pas cool parce qu'il
nous ment c'est ridicule donc voilà j'ai
que les groupes je sais que tu
travailles avec le groupe sur des
propositions
tu travailles voilà on radio aussi sur
des propositions donc tu n'oublieras
quand tu seras donc le tu sais que on a
eu nos trucs annoncé que à partir
d'aujourd'hui on s'échauffe et camille
ce week-end
et à partir de demain c'est ça mon cher
c'est demain je suis ton planning le
permet sur un tournoi de tennis à midi
mais je tourne avec toi trésor a prévu
de perdre livre à un sketch tous les
deux tous les soirs il y aura des
actrices y aura du norad et incluent
ceux de demain
ouais de mayorat désincruste wayne comme
à roland garros j'ai une question moi
j'aimais beaucoup il retrouve camille
qui a décidé d'arrêter ces personnes
arrêtées en fait à l'exil pas même les
faire ensemble a fait c'est qui fait
hyper froid et là ça va mieux donc on va
le faire mais en vrai dans un camion nos
prix mérité et 4 degrés on va en faire
ensemble camier mois les versions pro
gaming l'émission allait bien on à
libérer du temps pour faire d'autres
choses cette année puis voilà s'est pas
fait mais robin voie la vérité camille
jullien cartonne non mais ils en pensent
quoi camille je vous dernière était qu'à
midi la radio le matin c'est en plus sa
chronique le soir il est en plus ils en
pensent quoi camille je vous le dis il
l'année dernière camille j'ai cru que
j'allais le perdre il m'a dit il faut
que j'arrête un truc la radio il était
encore en contrat ils en pensent quoi
camille ça marchait très bien on voulait
absolument nous et la chaîne tu le sais
qu amy tu continues et non pas bien sûr
et la chronique on voulait absolument
qu'ils continuent aussi donc un moment
il m'a appelé et m'a chez imac et il m'a
dit cyril je garde la chronique pour pas
vous lâcher et je garde la radio et
malheureusement je pourrais pas
continuer il en pense quoi camille et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'en début
d'année oui on a un petit peu tâtonné en
à 18 heures avec la chaîne pour savoir
ce qu'on allait faire parce qu'on
comptait sur camille à 18 enfants
n'avaient envie que ce soit qu'animé
camion n'a compris voilà il peut pas
tout faire il pouvait par refaire une
année avec quotidienne à 18h la matinale
plus sa chronique tp on est un peu juste
mais plus médecin au make-up ouais c'est
ça va ça fait vraiment rendez vous
essentiel une chose beaucoup